find all of the factors of 120 or
another way to think about it find all
of the whole numbers that are that 120
is divisible by so the first one that's
maybe obvious all whole numbers are
divisible by one so we could write 120
it is equal to it is equal to one times
120 so let's write a factors list over
here factors factors right here so this
is going to be our factors list over
here so we just found two factors we
said well is it divisible by one well
every whole number is divisible by one
this is a whole number so one is a
factor at the low end one is a factor
that's it's actually low its smallest
factor its largest factor is 120 you
can't have something you can't have
something larger than 120 dividing
evenly into 120 hunt you know 121 will
not go into 120 so the largest factor on
our factors list is going to be 120 now
let's think about others let's think
about whether is 2 divisible into 120 so
does 120 equal 2 times something well
when you look here you immediately or
maybe you immediately recognize that 120
is an even number
it's ones place is a 0 as long as it's
ones place is a 0 2 4 6 or 8 as long as
it's an even number where the whole
number is even and the whole number is
divisible by 2 and to figure out what
you have to multiply by 2 to get 120
well you could think of well 120 is is
is 12 times 10 or another way to think
about it it's 2 times 6 times 10 or 2
times 60 you could divide it out if you
want you could say okay 2 goes into 120
2 goes into 1 no times 2 goes into 12 6
times 6 times 2 is 12 subtract you get 0
bring down the 0 2 goes into 0 0 times 0
times 2 is 0 and you get no remainder
there so it goes 60 times so we have two
more factors right here so we have the
factors so we've established so the next
lowest one is 2 and the next highest
factor if we're storing from the large
end is going to be 60 is 60 now let's
think about what
the three is 120 is 120 equal to three
times something well we could just try
to test and divide it from the get-go
but you hopefully already know the
divisibility rule to figure out if
something is divisible by three you add
up its digits and if the sum is
divisible by three we're in business
so if you take 120 so that you're
dealing with so this is one let me do it
over here one plus two plus zero well
that's equal to one plus two is three
plus zero is three and three is
definitely divisible by three so this is
120 is going to be divisible by three
and to figure what that number that you
have to multiply by three is you could
do it in your head you could say well 3
goes into 12 four times and then you
well let me just do it out just in case
just for those of you who want to see it
worked out 3 goes into 12 4 times 4
times 3 is 12 you subtract you're left
with nothing here you bring down this 0
3 toes into 0 0 times 0 times 3 is 0
nothing left over so it goes into it 40
times 40 times and the way to think of
it in your head is this is the same
thing as 12 times 10 12 divided by 3 is
4 but this is going to be 4 times 10
because you have that 10 left over
whatever works for you or you can just
ignore the 0 divided by 3 you get a 4
and then put the zero back there
whatever works so we have two more
factors at the low end we have a 3 and
at the high end we have a 40 we have a
40 now let's see if 4 is divisible into
120 now we saw the divisibility rule for
4 is you ignore everything beyond the
tens place and you just look at the last
two digits so if we're going to if we're
going to think about the whether 4 is
divisible you just look at the last two
digits the last two digits are 20 20 is
definitely divisible by 4 so 120 will be
divisible by 4 4 is going to be a factor
and to figure out what we have to
multiply 4 by to get 120 you could do it
in your head you could say 12 divided by
4 is 3 so 120 divided by 4 is 30
so we have two more factors four and
thirty and you could work this out long
division if you if you want to make sure
that this works out so let's keep going
and then we have we'll see what the 120
is equal to is five a factor is five
times something equal to 120 well you
can't do that simple well first of all
we could just test is it divisible and
120 ends with a 0 if you end with a 0 or
5 you are divisible by 5 so 5 definitely
goes into it and let's figure out how
many times so 5 goes into 120 doesn't go
into 1 it goes into 12 2 times 2 times 5
is 10
subtract you get to bring down the 0 5
goes into 20 4 times 4 times 5 is 20 and
then you subtract and then you subtract
and you have no leftover as we expect
because it should go in evenly this
number ends with a 0 or 5 so 5 let me
delete all this so we can have our
scratch space to work with later on so 5
times 24 is also equal to 120 so we have
2 more factors 5 and 24 and let me clear
up some space here because I think we're
going to be dealing with a lot of
factors so let me move this right here
so let me cut it and then let me paste
it move this over here so we have more
space for our factors so we have 5 and
24 let's move on to 6 so 120 is equal to
6 times what now did it be divisible by
6 you have to be divisible by 2 and 3
now we know that we're already divisible
by 2 and 3 so we're definitely going to
be divisible by 6 and you should
hopefully be able to do this one in your
head 5 was a little bit harder to do in
your head but 120 you could say well 12
divided by 6 is 2 and then you have that
0 there so 120 divided by 6 would be 20
and you could work it out long division
if you like so 6 times 20 are 2 more
factors 6 times 20 now let's think about
7 let's think about 7 here 7 is a very
bizarre number and just to test it you
could think of
other ways to do it let's just try to
divide 7 into 127 doesn't go into 1 it
goes into 12 one time 1 times 7 is 7
you subtract 12 minus 7 is 5 bring down
the 0 7 goes into 57 times 7 is 49 so it
goes into it 7 times 7 times 7 is 49
subtract you have a remainder so it does
not divide evenly so 7 does not work 7
does not work now let's think about 8
let's think about whether 8 works let's
think about 8 I'll do the same process
let's take 8 into 120 and just as a
little bit well let's just let's just
see let's just work it out and just as a
little bit of a hint well I'll just work
it out 8 goes into 12 it doesn't go into
1 so it goes into 12 one time 1 times 8
is 8 subtract there 12 minus 8 is 4
bring down the 0
8 goes into 40 5 times 5 times 8 is 40
and you're left with no remainder so it
goes evenly so 120 let me get rid of
that 120 120 is equal to 8 times 15 so
let's put add that to our factor list we
now have an 8 and now we have a and now
we have a 15 now is it divisible by 9 is
120 divisible by 9 to test that out you
just add up the digits 1 plus 2 plus 0
is equal to 3 well that satisfies our
three divisibility rule but 3 is not
divisible by 9 so our number will not be
divisible by 9 so 9 will not work out 9
does not work out so let's move on to 10
well this is pretty straightforward it
ends in 0 so we will be divisible by 10
so let me write that down 120 is equal
to 10 times and this is pretty
straightforward 10 times 12 you could
this is exactly what 120 is it's 10
times 12 so let's write those factors
down
and twelve and then we have one number
left we have eleven we don't have to go
above eleven because we already went
through twelve and we know that there
aren't any factors above that because we
did we these are we were going in
descending order so we've really filled
in all the gaps and you could try eleven
we could try it by hand if you like 11
goes into 120 now you know if you know
your multiplication tables through 11
that this won't work but I'll just show
you 11 goes into 12 one time 1 times 11
is 11 subtract 1 bring down the 0
11 goes into 10 0 times 0 times 11 is 0
you're left with a remainder of 10 so 11
goes into 20 10 times with the remainder
10 definitely does not go in evenly so
we have all of our factors here 1 2 3 4
5 6 8 10 12 15 20 24 30 40 60 and 120
and we're done